and there she is
live and in color
representative bartlett we're just
getting started in pam
is getting us hooked up to the live
stream
[Music]
you are ready to go thank you
so welcome everyone to our
uh hearing or our meeting
on uh our interim study bills um today
we're taking up seven of those bills
and tomorrow eight of them um
and uh bear with us as we manage this
process uh
it's obviously uh a little
different and new
and as i'm sure all of us know
these are not
votes that are going to move the bills
forward or
to kill them it's just going to make a
recommendation
either to recommend a bill for
future legislation or to not recommend
it for future legislation
a statement will go into the calendar to
that uh recommendation um
and uh there will be no vote uh in
from the house on um that statement
so this is the final piece of
um dispensing or
managing the bills that have come before
us um
and um let me
do the opening script
as chair of the house commerce and
consumer affairs committee i find that
due to the state of emergency declared
by the governor
as a result of the covet 19 pandemic and
in accordance with the governor's
emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
please note that there is no physical
location to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting which
was authorized pursuant to the
governor's emergency order
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that we
are um with provision a providing public
access to the meeting by telephone
with additional access possibilities by
video or
other electronic means we are utilizing
zoom for this electronic meeting
all members of the committee and select
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through this platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary
participate in this meeting by clicking
on the following website address
https colon forward slash forward slash
zoom dot u s forward slash
j forward slash 99708430633
or dialing one of the following phone
numbers one
three one two six two six six seven nine
nine
four one nine two nine two zero
five six zero nine to nine provision b
providing public notice of the necessary
information for accessing the meeting
we previously gave notice to the public
of the necessary information for
accessing the meeting
including how to access the meeting
using zoom or telephonically
this information is printed in the house
calendar
provision c providing mechanism for the
public to alert the public body
during the meeting if there are problems
with access
if anybody has a problem please call 271
or email at hcs
leg.state.nh.us
provision d adjourning the meeting if
the public is unable to access
the meeting in the event the public is
unable to access the meeting the meeting
will be adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting us
pam smarling is the meeting host
additional staff providing support are
christina dyer
and brad greenland this is a work
session on bills referred to the
commerce committee for interim study
and we're going to have a discussion on
each individual bill
and exec that bill after that discussion
rather than exec all the bills at the
end of the meeting
copies of the interim study bills have
been posted on the main page of the
general court website
under the heading remote meetings please
note that all
votes that are taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call vote
and our clerk today is representative
weston
and let's start uh the meeting by taking
roll call attendance when each member
states their presence please
also state whether there is anyone in
the room with you during the meeting
which is required under the right to
know law
that's the end of that little speech
representative weston okay
vice president william oops
i'm going to take your mute
why is it got an echo
did you hear me i did so i am
i am present i am in my home
and my cockatiel is in the room with me
and she may decide to weigh in
on any of the bills thank you
representative gage not here
representative abel representative abel
as present in west lebanon
and i'm by myself
representative bartlett
i'm you unmute
sorry um i am present and i'm in my home
in concord
and there's no one else in the room
representative herbert
not here representative macbeth
representative macbeth is present
in her home office in portsmouth new
hampshire and she's alone
representative van houghton i'm present
i'm in the study in my manchester home
and i am alone
representative fargo i'm present
i'm in the study of my home in dover new
hampshire and i'm alone
representative indrik
i am present calling in from my office
in nashua
and i am alone representative weston
i am here in my office in plymouth new
hampshire and i'm alone
representative hunt i am in
wicapog rhode island which is a fire
district of the town of westerly
and i am in the upstairs farthest
bedroom i could be because i
do have grandchildren in the house so
hopefully they will not here
storm the room representative sanborn
not here representative osborne
uh here at home in auburn new hampshire
alone and the door is locked so i should
be
left alone representative plummer
john plummer not here uh he's here you
you need to remember to to use the star
six to i mean this
representative plumber here
in belmont new hampshire in my office
alone
thank you representative barnes
you're new
is present at 18 sunset avenue
derry new hampshire upstairs in my hobby
room
and i am by myself thank you
representative warden i am here
in my home in manchester and i am alone
chairman butler i am here in my
uh home office in hart's location and
i'm alone
thank you and uh
we will uh discuss the bills uh as they
were presented in order
uh in the calendar and representative
williams is going to
direct the discussion in these bills um
when that discussion is completed then i
will call for a motion
and uh we will have um a
roll call vote uh representative
williams
thank you mr chairman so i would open
discussion on
hb 405 which is
relative to beer and refillable seniors
and i see no hands from the committee
and i see no hands from
the attendees and everyone uh hopefully
is familiar with the hand raising
mechanism
and zoom so if you choose to speak
please use the zoom hand raise
to indicate that you want to speak so
since this is my bill i'll
i will speak on it this this bill
is one that uh has always been quite
popular in the house
has passed the house by a wide margin
300 votes or more
typically and uh but we've always
struggled with it on the senate side
and so this time we decided we weren't
it wasn't quite ready
and needs to have some additional uh
work done
uh to make it uh universally attractive
uh so um i would
consider this uh a bill that we should
do when we obviously passed
uh a temporary um bill
around growlers uh
based on the restaurants struggling in
the pandemic and and i think that
there will continue to be issues for
restaurants
and anything that we can do to make
restaurants uh give restaurants
um additional business would be
would be useful and this has always been
to me a a bill that's uh
really intended for consumers it gives
consumers the option
if they choose to get fresh beer
as a takeout item uh
instead of buying a beer that's been
packaged at the factory which
does have a different taste to it and
if you want a particular brand um
especially from the smaller uh breweries
you don't necessarily want to be able to
one have to drive you know 100 miles or
more to get to that brewery but if you
can get it from
a local restaurant or a
a beer specialty store there's
definitely a benefit
so um i will
attempt going forward to make this
uh bill more accessible uh more
interesting to
the small companies who who have been
the main obstacle on the senate side
thank you and ms smarling i don't see uh
representative hunt has his hand raised
that's when you didn't see a hand
there's a hand
[Laughter]
right i thought it was appropriate to
let representative williams speak
first so um so obviously i have
supported the
concept of growlers in the past and
um and certainly agree
that you know we would like to do
something uh to offer this opportunity
but
um i guess i'm i'm i'm a little cautious
about today's vote
because when we say recommend or not
recommend for mutual legislation and
it's true there's a blurb that goes with
it
um what has occurred uh certainly in
this year is
a whole myriad of new issues have come
up around
the concept of the growlers and the
benefit to the growlers to
let's say the the restaurant and lodging
we're not lodging with a restaurant
you know uh lobby group and so the issue
being that uh boy it would have been
nice if they had it they could get rid
of their beer all right
um i would say i would counter to what
you one comment you made which is
that it's a different growler beer is
different than what you would get
um you know from bottled beer or canned
beer
um but it's not different than the cake
uh growler beer is you know in terms of
when are they with the keges whether
it's been
um filtered and fermented they um
the filtering process that uh many
growler bills
growlers are not and that's the reason
why they like growler so this is that
it's it's a much more pure beer and has
not been pasteurized
which is what you're going to get in a
keg which is what you're going to go to
the grocery stores
so the long shot the short of it is um
i'm i i was okay with uh retaining this
bill with the assumption
that we're going to get a chance to work
on it and try to figure out something
that's going to make this
work and certainly get senators and you
know involved or so you know in terms of
trying to figure out what the issue is
but it's it's not so much the senate
it's the action the reality is it's the
small
custom brewers so obviously
theoretically a large brewer would not
have a problem with this um
you know they they got the kegs they're
pushing them out they're more than happy
to
uh if uh and you know retail and then we
haven't even talked about the difference
between
uh on-premise licensing versus
off-premise licenses
um when you say you know here we're
talking about you know you're talking
about an
on-premise licensee um but you know
there's plenty of on
off premises you know grocery stores
they would like to have it too you know
and
and that that's the one was a big
pushback by the commission
um worry about the pipes cleaning
worrying about the controls over there's
you know all these myriad of issues that
are going on with this
this bill so i gets down to what i would
call the uh rule of thumb for
liquor bills and that is who is there's
this general demand push
for something okay in other words we are
when it comes to liquid laws where
mother may i
and we do what people you know they say
well we really want this i really need
there's a need for it
the reality is the growlers is not a
problem for anybody to get a growler
and they don't have to go very far to
get one um we have
you know you know we think of the nanos
we got 20 some plus
nanos we got brewers are popping up
every day
and so anybody can go get a growler and
frankly those custom brewers are
perfectly happy doing it that way
because they make more money if you go
buy it from them
and not through uh you know putting it
in a keg and throwing it to a
to a retailer or off-premise license or
on-premise license here whichever we end
up choosing
so i i'm at the point now i don't really
see the customer demand for growlers
uh if a customer wants a growler they
really don't have to drive far to go get
one
and and so i i think at this point
unless there is a great outcry from
the cut the small brewers the people who
are actually we would want to
benefit to the small the small custom
brewers
unless there's someone will cry for them
to do this bill i just think it's
it's time to give growlers a rest for a
while
uh and not you know not bother bringing
something in next year because
you you know the times you know if
you're going to bring the bill in you're
bringing the same language
you're going to have the same problem we
had this year or last year you know
every year um you know we it really you
know we had a study committee once
already
and they didn't they didn't come up with
anything right i mean there was no there
was no resolution
and so you know this is an issue that i
i just think that
it it at this point it's we're better
off just leave a sleeping dog lie
thank you representative hunt and i see
a
hand from um the audience
uh ms marlene can you uh
elevate mr moore uh into
our group sure you also saw that you
have a couple of committee
hands no i didn't thank you that's all
right
representative patusek was first and
then representative van houghton
and representative williams if you want
to continue
sure so uh i would call on
representative petruccio
uh he's been waiting the longest so
go ahead thank you uh representative
williams
uh i have been contacted over the over
this
period of time uh by a couple of the
local
uh micro nano brewers uh as you know
dairy in londonderry have a
ton of local brewers and
none of them seem to feel that they
really needed this bill
back in the day when it was started yeah
but
lately and locally they don't
see a need for it thank you
and representative van halen thank you
um i i tend to agree with the two
previous speakers
the issues that were never really
resolved when we first heard the bill
include things like sanitation how do we
keep the
the growlers sanitary moving forward uh
the advent or the advent of the
popularity of canned beers
coming in so i think the face of of the
market that we're looking at here that
we're trying to deal with as as
representative hunt
mentioned really has seen its heyday and
um i
don't see that moving this bill forward
at this time or at least putting it
forward in terms of a recommendation to
move it forward
is in the best interests of of the group
thank you
so i would remind you all that uh there
are 33 states that have that allow
other other entities besides the people
who produce the beer
to fill growlers you go to new york
state and almost
you can find brawler filling stations
all over the place
and they don't have issues uh
with sanitation or with
concerns from the small brewers i mean
you guys
both mentioned the small brewers
they are actually the ones who uh have
objected
really the only ones who objected to the
growler bill in the past
and that was because as representative
punt said
they make more money filling growlers
than if they sell
their beer in a keg or in a can because
they're getting
essentially a retail price for something
um
but i i think that i so i continue to
have people talk to me who are consumers
who would like to be able to do this uh
representative hunt says you can get a
growler
um not very far from your home but
that's
that may be true it depends on where you
live obviously but that means you're
getting it from the closest brewery to
you
if you don't happen to like their beer
versus someone else's beer
you know if i live in wilton and i but i
happen to like beer from moat mountain
in
in ed's area um that means i have to
drive you know
almost 100 miles to to get my beer
i'm not going to do that for a growler
and uh
so aidan moore if uh
the representative abel has his hand up
so we're gonna
follow that good policy of talking to
our
or calling on our reps first and then
the audience
i would call on representative abel
thank you
thank you um i think that we
should recommend uh this uh this
build for uh reintroduction
next year um considering the fact that
there was a strong testimony
uh in favor of this this is a long-term
uh bill uh i think at least this
at least three times this bill has come
up before us
um and because there were only
a few uh
a few things that that were still
controversial
and the sponsor believes that we can
we can um find solutions to those
i think that we should and they
recommend that he go ahead and and and
do that
and i think the bill will come back
whether we recommend it or not
and i would like
representative bartlett
you're muted thank you um
i have to agree with representative van
houten um
i think that there were other issues on
this i do
think that um
with particularly with the pandemic and
all of the
cleanliness issues that are you know
going to be we're going to be addressing
for a long time
um i don't think that this one's ready
to come back and i think
um i'm i'm going to vote against
recommending
it for further
pam legislation you uh promote uh mr
moore
so he can speak to us absolutely
he should be on his way there he is
good afternoon committee members uh can
you hear me okay
yes thank you um i guess i have
more uh of a question for you
representative williams
and and i'm not sure for the benefit of
the committee
as you may or may not recall hospital
was had a number of uh
issues in it that were of concern to us
at the liquor commission um such as
putting us into the position of kind of
almost becoming a
product integrity for the manufacturer
uh training and doing health uh training
for
draft line maintenance and a few other
things so i
i i think there were a number of
concerns with 405 the way
it was drafted and i guess my question
to you representative williams is
is it your intention to bring 405 if the
committee were to
vote to reintroduce this to bring it
back as it currently
exists or are you going to
amend it in some way um
and i'm not sure mr chairman uh you
you may or may not recall that at the
last legislative session
house bill 1717 made it through the
rules committee to come to the floor
which
was a bill that would allow
on-premise licensees to sell draft beer
if a pandemic existed
um that kind of languished i i don't
believe it ever
made it to any type of vote but i guess
my question representative williams is
is your intention to bring this back as
it is currently written
um sure happy to answer that question
and by the way we did vote on the on
and passed it in um in the
in the house i not sure where it went
after that i don't think it went through
the senate
but um certainly i would not bring it
back
as written um it needs to be
a different bill it needs to be modified
because the reason why it went to
interim study is because
there were concerns and i would
certainly
i recognize the the issues
that were added to the liquor
commission's
set of responsibilities were mainly done
because
there were concerns from the
the manufacturer side in terms of
draft system cleaning
and and some other things um
i'm not it's not clear to me that that
those are
legitimate concerns because
having researched how the 33 states that
allow growlers to be filled by people
outside of the
the industry there don't seem to be
anybody
else that there isn't seem to be anybody
else who is
you know requiring the training on
cleaning and those kinds of things
but i i would certainly if i bring this
back
uh it won't be the same bill it'll be
it'll be substantially different
and our recommendation for future
legislation
or not um is a
uh general recommendation i don't think
it
in any way uh mandates that the bill
come back
um in the exact form that it is current
that it currently exists it's the
subject not
the bill itself right and so
representative williams do you have a
motion to make
sure i would move that we uh recommend
uh house bill 405 for future legislation
thank you and representative weston when
you are ready if you would call the roll
you have a second do we need a second
maybe
um and i will second
okay uh vice chairman williams yes
representative gage not here
representative
abel yes representative bartlett
representative bartlett
i thought nope i can't tell which one
it's which button to push
um no representative herbert
not here representative macbeth
no representative van houghton
no representative fargo
now representative indrik
yes representative weston
no representative hunt no
representative sanborn not here
representative osborne yes
representative plummer
not is representative plummer here he is
he needs to unmute representative
plumber
with your star six
no that was a no
that was a no thank you
representative barnes no
representative
yes we have one two three four
five yes and
you missed representative butler oh i'm
sorry
chairman butler that's okay yes i will i
vote yes
so six to nine the motion does not pass
do i have another motion
not recommended representative hunt
moves not recommended for future
legislation is there a second
second representative bartlett seconds
and when the clerk is ready she will
call the roll
vice chairman williams no
[Music]
representative gage
uh not here representative abel
no representative bartlett
yes representative herbert
oh i'm sorry you're right uh
representative macbeth
yes representative van houghton
yes representative fargo yes
representative indrik no
representative weston yes
representative hunt yes
representative sanborn not here
representative
osborne yes representative plummer
oh you dismuted yourself you were
unmuted
back to star six
yes representative barnes
yes representative
yes oh wait a minute
i just put it in the wrong place plumber
was
yes or no correct it was a yes
barnes was yes empatusik was yes
correct uh representative warden
yes yes okay
so and i will vote no i'm sorry
you won't know i'll get it
so this is for not recommended
um we have
one two three four nays
and
eleven yes
thank you
thank you for that and i'll bring the
bill anyway
knew you would we knew yeah we knew that
so uh we'll move on to uh house bill
which is relative to the definition of
specialty cider
uh who would like to speak on this bill
me so uh i'll recognize it
so uh yes i am the sponsor of this bill
and i have good news
uh this the uh the primary issue of this
bill is no longer necessary
um you might require a remember that i
first started out was
that the uh issue was that when we
passed uh
allow in-state beverage manufacturers to
have a higher or higher content of
alcohol
it didn't include out-of-state and but
now
uh we have a new legislation that just
got passed uh
you know but never came to the committee
we kind of missed out on the fund
uh but this bill was a senate bill and
um this bill will certainly allow
a cider manufacturer uh to be able to
bring in a higher alcohol content
from out of state into new hampshire so
at this point in time the bill is not
necessary so i move
uh not recommended for future
legislation
second manhattan
anyone else like to speak so we have a
motion and a second to
not recommend for future legislation i
see no more hands mr chairman
thank you and the clerk will call the
roll on not recommended
on the house bill 1300
vice chairman williams yes
uh representative gage not here
uh representative abel uh
yes representative bartlett
yes representative herbert
not here not here i'm sorry uh
representative macbeth
yes representative van houghton yes
representative fargo yes representative
indrick
yes representative weston yes
representative hunt yes
representative sanborn not here
representative osborne
yes representative plummer
he needs to unmute
yes representative barnes
yes representative
yes representative warden
yes chairman butler yes
we have one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten
eleven dollars fifteen
yay
so uh house bill 1300 uh will go
on uh in the calendar as not recommended
and representative hunt you'll do uh
statements on the last two bills
thank you
all right so we'll move on to house bill
or 613 which is relative to mandatory
automobile insurance
and who would like to speak or is anyone
who would like to speak on
this particular bill
i there so there is one hand in the
audience well that now that hands
all i see is representative macbeth's
hand okay so uh
representative mcbeth thank you um
so i um this is a bill that i
would like to see go forward i think we
had compelling testimony
from people that had been injured by
um the fault of an uninsured or
underinsured
driver in new hampshire um i know that
uh there was that
last minute or poll voting i'm in the
house
um which i i'd disregard as far as that
as far as
sincere interest over mandatory
insurance i don't think that members
really understood it although i
appreciate the effort to try to gauge
interest but this is a bill i'd like to
go forward just as a consumer
protection bill thank you
and representative bartlett thank you um
oh representative macbeth i really
appreciate your support on this one
um i don't think we have a motion on the
floor
do we we do not and well we will at the
end of the
uh of the discussion okay
um this is this is the uh work part of
the uh
thing and then we move on to the
executive session
okay sorry um i mean the hard part i
think
for me you know that i also that i feel
strongly that we should
not be the only state without mandatory
auto insurance
however with the insurance department
not in favor without insurance companies
not in favor and the town clerks
um also coming out in opposition
um it's really hard to to see how we
can do it in this form um i think that
there are other times when
maybe there's another way we can look
into it
but it just feels like new hampshire
has with this i think it was 13 times i
don't know my notes in front of me but i
think it's been
in front of us 13 times since 1991.
um in this form i don't think it's going
to move
i think we're going to have enough work
next term
to keep us all very busy so i'm i
against my better judgment
really i'm going to say i'm not going to
recommend this for
future legislation representative
williams
um i apparently as a co-host can't raise
my hand so put me in the list please
okay so um representative abel first and
then representative
butler okay thank you um
i have to say that this bill has always
or this issue has always baffled me uh
i've lived in a lot of states and
uh mandatory uh automobile insurance was
in every one of them it seemed to work
wonderfully
uh it prevented a lot of the problems
that we heard
uh in terms of testimony
from people who had been injured and
suffered because they
were unable to collect from people who
were uninsured
um i did i have to say i didn't hear a
single
good what i thought was a single good
reason for why we
when we had testimony before for why we
should keep the system the way it is now
i bet most people you know in new
hampshire
a lot of people don't even realize this
is the case and they're
very surprised and adversely affected
um so um i i'm a very strong proponent
that we should have sexual law and i
still wait to hear reasons for why we
shouldn't do that
and i'm just presenting my point of view
thank you
and representative butler thank you um
representative abel in those states that
you have lived and i have lived uh where
it was mandatory
we may not have heard the problems
with uninsured motorists
because there was a law mandating it
however we've also heard in the
testimony
from several different perspectives
that even in the states that have
mandatory
requirement for auto insurance there are
several that
have uh more uninsured motorists than we
do
so the problem exists we may not have
heard about it in
those states that we lived in uh
that required it um i
uh we put this bill in
for interim study because i believe
there's a real
um uh challenge to
creating a law if we are going to
mandate it that is going to be
successful
um uh those if
what uh we mandate is a minimum coverage
of 25 000
which is what is required as a minimum
for coverage in
many mandated states then that's not
necessarily going to
achieve the coverage that some of those
people that we heard of
are going to need and they're still
going to be in the same situation that
they were in
in terms of recompense for the damages
that occurred to them
um i don't think that mandatory auto
insurance
um is the answer
to the problems that were brought to us
if we have
a nine percent uh
uh uninsured population in the state
and in some other states that mandate it
there is a percentage of uninsured
motorists that is greater than that
then i don't know that mandatory
insurance is the answer
um so uh i don't
you know uh i i will look forward to the
solution
that uh the new hampshire legislature
comes up with
so i would i would agree uh
with representative butler that as the
bill was written
and and you know rewriting it is a
difficult problem
but as the bill was written it really
wasn't going to provide much
help for the motorist who
is injured by an uninsured motorist
because
even if that motorist the motorist is
not likely to choose to you know buy
three hundred thousand dollars worth of
liability if they're
going from uninsured to insured they're
gonna buy them the minimum
uh which as representative butler said
would probably be twenty or twenty
twenty five thousand dollars um and that
won't make that much difference in terms
of them recovering from their injuries
in fact they're more likely to benefit
from
the the rule which requires the
insurance company to provide uninsured
motorist coverage
that's the equivalent of the liability
coverage that an individual carries and
so
people who are concerned about uninsured
motorists should have lots of liability
coverage because then if they are struck
by an uninsured motorist they'll
get that uh coverage which won't pay
them for pain and suffering but will
certainly pay them for
medical costs um and
uh somebody mentioned i think maybe
christie mentioned the
town clerks uh and and that's
the way the bill was written it put a
burden on
uh tom clerks to be basically enforcing
this law um i think that
is something that i don't know if that's
what happens in other states
it's it's possible that that you have to
show proof of insurance to register a
car but
it's not something that uh has been in
the process here
ever and so i think it makes it very
difficult for people to deal with that
so i think
maybe there's a way to do this i'm not
sure what that is
and certainly the way the bill was
written i don't think we can move
forward
i would call on representative indrik
who hasn't spoken yet
thank you representative williams i
certainly appreciate
all of the concerns everyone has
expressed and recognized that this would
not be
easy to create a
form that would be easily passable and
reconcilable between all the different
parties i did just want to
as a representative from a more densely
settled area
did want to recognize that there are
many individuals particularly in nashua
who are pedestrians and do not have auto
insurance and as such
do not have that possibility of having
an uninsured motorist coverage
to their own policy and it is certainly
something that every summer when i see
folks out on their bikes and out walking
around the streets and people speeding
by
uh to me i cringe and i think what
happens when
one of these poor individuals on their
way to work gets uh
into a vehicular accident with a
uninsured motorist
and is certainly something that weighs
on my mind and i see becoming
more pressing issue in this area as we
continue to grow and see more and more
individuals who are
commuting to work by bike or walking
and it is certainly something that
weighs on my mind and i would very much
like to see this state
join the 49 other states and do what i
think is the right thing however i
recognize
this is not an easy task and respect
everyone's decision accordingly
representative bartlett thanks um
representative indrick brings up a
really good point regarding coverage
under um um for pedestrians or bike
riders
um i'm i'm just putting in two cents
to guard as i know i'm not going to win
this battle um
but the minimum limits are rarely
sold um
they usually their much higher limits
are sold right off the bat
um because there's not a lot of
difference between
what you pay for minimum limits than
what you pay for
higher limits but i i you know i i think
this is
a battle that the way this bill is
written
until in new hampshire decides to
become more automated because
massachusetts used to
used to make it much more difficult to
prove insurance and it's all automated
now
we're just not there um as far as
monitoring
so i i i give up
that's all representative hunt
yeah uh so not that i want to pick a
fight with you chrissy but
now it's actually the people who cannot
afford insurance are going to buy
the least expensive one and they're
going to buy the 25.50
and and and i think that i ironically in
new hampshire
because we don't have it mandatory so
the people every you know
someone someone who buys insurance the
insurance agent is going to
make them understand that you don't have
to buy this
but you're buying it to protect yourself
don't worry about the other guy
you're worried about yourself making
sure you have enough coverage
make sure you get the benefits that
you're going to need if you're in a
serious accident
and i think that's the reason why in new
hampshire we actually have
people with higher uh uh balance
you know higher amounts than other
states because
that conversation occurs and the only
reason it occurs is because we don't
have mandatory auto insurance
you know and you know let's face it if
it gets down to
making a choice of what you're going to
pay for
and insurance to buy what would we
rather people be buying
auto insurance or health insurance
i think i want them to buy the health
insurance
so i see no more hands
represented butler uh thank you
the executive side yeah i will move
uh not recommended for future
legislation on
house bill 613 and uh
i'm not sure representative bartlett
that that will
pass but that is my recommendation
and i will second that representative
williams thank you
and the clerk when you are ready
uh vice chairman williams yes
gage representative gage not here
representative abel
no representative bartlett
i have to vote no
representative herbert not here
not here uh representative macbeth
representative in fact votes
yeah yes well
it's not recommended so um
so i vote no but on behalf of myself and
all the other guys out there
thank you representative van houghton
need to unmute no sorry you
vote no yeah no representative fargo
no representative indra
no representative weston
i vote no representative hunt
yes representative sanborn not here
representative osborne yes
representative plummer
yes representative warden
yes and chairman butler
yes one two three four five
seven eight eight two three
seven so the not recommended
uh uh passes motion passes
not recommended passes
okay so we'll move on to house bill
1320 which establishes a renter's
insurance notification requirement
and so we're back in in work session
mode is it would anyone like to speak on
this bill
representative bartlett thank you um
you know what i'm going to say i'm i
really feel strongly that
um the the tenant's lease
should state clearly that
the landlord's policy does not cover
them
for property damage or for liability
um that there is no coverage
under under the policy for the tenant
so i have got to recommend that this be
brought forward we had testimony from
um tenants that had absolutely no
understanding
that they did not have insurance
coverage and it
affected them when tragedy hit
so i really feel that it there should be
just one sentence
in the lease agreement that says
we don't you know there's no coverage
for you and we recommend that you have
renters insurance
pretty simple it would affect you
representative thank you
um while i feel definite sorry and
sadness for anyone who has any kind of a
loss
i'm not sure this type of legislation is
necessary
nor does it accomplish the goals of
legislation per se
it is more education and perhaps it
should be elsewhere that we educate
renters about this but to put it into a
into a rental agreement is saying that
you know we don't we don't allow people
to understand what they're doing we
don't give them
credit for what they're doing and i also
need to just put a quick disclaimer here
when i first spoke on on this bill
whenever whenever we had the first work
session i was a land landlord landlady
land person let's go with that and i no
longer am
i simply think that this is something
that
citizens need to be educated on and i do
agree they need to be educated on this
but i don't believe that that
legislation is the place for that to
happen
representative thank you representative
williams
um i support this bill as another
consumer
um rights advocacy bill i think it's
very similar to some of the issues that
we had on the
story units contracts that we as a
committee
rewrote and put in big bold or colored
highlighted terms
particular issues that we thought were
important
to consumers that they might not realize
and i think i see this is another one of
those
issues and i think particularly with the
scarcity of rental property in our state
a lot of renters are going to be you
know um
doing things quickly and might not be
able to get all the education they need
um and so i would just it's a one
sentence and it's uh
good for both the landlord and the
tenant and
i'd like to see it included thank you
representative uh thank you
representative williams
um i wrote an op-ed piece uh for the
dairy news and the lawrence eagle
tribune
the lawrence eagle tribune serves the
area of salem
where this the fires etc took place
and most of all the representatives that
are sponsors
had a chance to read it i also posted it
in facebook
and to be honest i did not get
any feedback whatsoever whether positive
or negative on this article
so uh it was nice that
i shared it with the folks but nobody
said
we should have a vote for it or go
against it
thank you representative bartlett
well my i'm just going to
reiterate that landlords don't even know
that their insurance
doesn't cover their tenants only if they
do something grossly negligent
um and i think that it's protection for
the landlords as well
uh you know can i ask you representative
van outen when you were a landlady
did you have it in your lease
oops i did not
i i'm in my defendant i shouldn't say in
my defense i did inform them
that insurance was uh that i enjoyed the
building itself and not their contents
of the building
but to just tell them verbally is really
not enough people forget
well i think that that's true but we're
talking about adults who are renting
rental properties here and i'm really
not fighting you on this because i
really do believe that people should be
educated about their rights and their
consumer responsibilities
but i'm just not sure that that's
something that should be in the lease
but how many people understand
uh thank you i do recall in part of this
conversation
i had reached out to the new hampshire
housing authority to see if
there was a possibility of perhaps them
working with
new hampshire legal aid to draft a
general
disclosure sheet similar to the lead
paint disclosure sheet
that could be distributed with leases
which obviously could take very many
different forms and could be required or
could be just accessible
and it seems to me that that a a tool or
a resource such as that
could really provide the opportunity to
educate
both landlords and renters and be made
readily available and with the input of
new hampshire legal aid really could
contain lots of information that could
be beneficial
and it seems that that might be a way to
avoid
some of the concern about meddling in
rental agreements
and specifying particular language which
may or may not be appropriate
uh to the particular circumstances
so i i would agree with that um i think
it isn't necessarily i think
representative van houden said it isn't
this
isn't really a subject for legislation i
think
if we could get an agency like
legal aid or new hampshire housing or
someone else to
provide education and the distribution
of that information
i think it would be useful but i think
putting it into
the lease agreement which is what this
bill required
isn't really much help i i don't know
how many of you have recently read lease
agreements maybe maybe you you have
representative n out in a few
leased property but they tend to be
fairly long
um and uh depending on where this sits
in that lease agreement the renter may
not even
see it i i i can tell you that
uh people in general don't read
long legal agreements because they don't
necessarily understand them
and they're kind of boring and and
they figure that they don't have any
choice if they want to do whatever it is
that that agreement is for whether it's
to
lease a an apartment or or buy a car
or whatever and so they just sign it um
and so certainly education
so that people are aware of you know
what their
responsibilities are and what their
liabilities are
is useful but i don't think the way the
bill was written
uh that problem is solved and i'm not
sure that legislation is the appropriate
way to do this
and i see representative abel's hand
representative abel
uh you muted yourself
rich you're muted
representative there there you go there
we go i've got it thank you
thank you um sorry um with the
understanding
that what we're talking about
or what we would be voting on is not the
bill
that we heard in in this year
but instead of the concept
i would like to encourage us to to
uh recommend that that uh
something be done and if and it
it could be as simple as having the
landlord
pass out a short statement
that says you're not in you know we
don't insure you
uh it doesn't have to be in the lease
agreement but if we recommend the bill
then the sponsors
would be encouraged to come back and do
that it would be simpler and i think
everybody would like it so i'm in favor
of recommending
by recommending this this subject
and representative williams yes so
um as i as i just said i don't believe
this is the appropriate
item for legislation and the thing that
we haven't talked about is what the
enforcement mechanism is here
you know are we going to have the
attorney general go after the
landlords because they they don't have
the proper information in their
lease agreements i mean there will there
will be no enforcement
uh you know i can i think i could state
that pretty clearly
and so therefore putting it into
legislation putting it into the
the rsas uh doesn't really make much
sense
um again and certainly i i support
100 what representative indrex said
which is encouraging
uh somebody to provide education um
you know getting landlords to distribute
information
uh those are all useful but you know
putting in something that essentially
requires something to be put into
a lease agreement with with no teeth
with no enforcement nobody's going to
you know be checking those um i don't
think it makes sense so so i would move
that we do not recommend this for uh
future legislation
is there a second second
representative uh hunt spoke up before
representative
houghton raised her hand i couldn't find
the button
and the clerk will call the roll on uh
not recommended
for house bill 1320.
that's chairman williams yes
representative giggs not here
representative abel
no representative bartlett
no i'm sorry who is that yes or no
no no representative
herbert not here representative macbeth
no representative van hounten
yes representative fargo
yes representative indrik
yes representative weston
yes representative hunt
no no yes excuse me i don't know
confused yes representative sanborn's
not here
represented osborne yes
representative plummer yes
representative barnes yes
representative yes
representative warden yes
and chairman butler yes
i'm sorry
twelve yays three nos
so not recommended on house bill 1320
moves forward
and representative williams will write a
statement
yeah absolutely so we'll move on to
house bill 1464. which
was relative to insurance coverage for
yoga therapy as an alternative or
substitute for opioids
and so we're back in work work session
mode is there anyone who would like to
speak on this
representative williams if i could uh
comment
representative butler thank you um
this one is a challenge for me because
i uh have supported and
worked with alternative healthcare
therapies
since early in my uh
career as a nurse
but i don't think that this bill
is ready for prime time um
uh i think that uh there are so many
forms of yoga therapy
and there may be uh
some states that are currently covering
yoga therapy for certain interventions
but i think we need a lot more
uh understanding and work on this
and um others have
uh suggested that maybe there is a way
to look at
several alternative therapies so we've
covered
acupuncture therapy and certainly
physical therapy is covered and
some other interventions
uh even when for massage medically
uh required are covered but i don't
think that there
is a comprehensive understanding
of alternative therapies and their
impact
and how they could be covered what is
the process
acupuncturists have a
an association and a process for
certification
um but uh i don't know that there is
that for yoga therapy
um so i don't
i don't see how we can support this
other than to say um it
is uh something that
needs to to we need to continue to work
for it but um i don't think it's this
bill
should be recommended representative
representative um yeah
i was confused because i thought you
were going to say recommended for future
legislation i know
so uh yeah so i i just want to make sure
everybody
stands as someone who's been around for
of the mandates that we have passed
acupuncture is not a mandated benefit i
mean these are
these even physical therapy we had some
big long debates about the physical
therapy that's not
actually mandated it's not in the
statute um
so the the first question he always says
is has there actually been
a uh uh
the therapist or somebody who is
recommending yoga therapy
and their insurance company uh whoever
that person had
or the patient refused to pay it do we
actually know that that actually
occurred
um so and i don't think we even got
there because i think we were kind of
bogged down in the hearing that there
wasn't
any real certifications yet for
a yoga profession so we were kind of
like overwhelmed that that
compared to all our other mandates where
everybody's usually licensed and
and registered you know before they come
in and look for the mandate
so um all i'm saying is is that you know
that
i i'm i wouldn't be surprised that there
plenty of people do get yoga therapy is
it you know for alternative
i'm sure it is available i'm sure some
of you are getting it just like they're
getting acupuncture and
they're getting other things um so i i
think that
if for us to even go anywhere this
there's a lot more
knowledge needs to be gained or what the
issues are out there about uh
whether this is really a problem or not
representative
thank you um i actually have very little
to add i think that the conversations
that have preceded my
statements now are exactly where i stand
um
i do i do see a lot of value to
different types of alternative therapies
but the efficacy of value for um for
yoga therapy has not been brought to us
we don't
know we don't see evaluations and
studies we see a variety of different
credentialing and licensing
among those who administer this type of
therapy and i think we're seeing in the
evolution of forms it's becoming a more
popular therapy
and i think that they're branching out
to dance therapy dance
yoga and so on so while i i applaud
um the ability of medicine to go into
other areas that can
maybe less invasively help people with
with medical issues with
um with pains and aches i i just don't
think that this bill is something that
we can move forward with
at this time
so um the city sitting on gel car now
um i see the process of
the licensing process uh in a lot more
detail and
one of the things that i think is an
issue is that if there isn't a license
or a board that somehow certifies uh
practitioners it'll be a lot more of a
struggle to get insurance companies to
to pay because insurance companies tend
to
want to to be able to without them doing
the work
to be able to verify that someone is
actually providing a service that is
uh useful to the patient that actually
provides some
uh some medical relief and
without any any process other than just
somebody saying i'm using this
uh practitioner for therapy
um that's probably not going to be
enough for an insurance company
whether it's you know something that's
mandated or not
um they're going to want to see a
licensing process i
it require i recall in the discussion
around this that there was some talk
about
a study effort that was going to look at
alternative therapies in
general and to try to come up with a
mechanism
for putting those forward in a more
professional structure you know with
some sort of
board of practitioners or something
and it seems to me as though that's
where this needs to go
i don't know it's probable that that
board
or that study never actually finished
its work just like
most of those other studies didn't
finish their work because of the
pandemic but
i think that that's where we need to go
before we move forward and try to
require a one particular alternative
therapy representative williams before
you go on
um i would want to ask ms smarling um
to uh let the uh attendees know
how they can um raise their hand to
speak
um just to make sure that everybody has
that information
sure and i see the sponsor of this bill
in in the attendees list and perhaps
she'd like to speak on this
yeah i see her as well and um for the
attendees if you're on a
pc if you go down to the bottom of the
participants list if you go down to the
bottom of the list where you see all
your names uh for the attendees side
you should see a button that says raise
your hand
or else maybe a button with three dots
on it that
indicates more and and so if you don't
see the
raise your hand at the bottom of the
screen of that column
check the the more button to see if
raised your hand is there
and if you're on the oh there's a hand
um and look at that it's representative
so i'm bringing her in i hope that was
uh
what you were excused please do
and there she is
welcome to commerce we just need to have
you unmute yourself
there you go thank you mr chairman thank
you
committee for letting me speak um i hear
your concerns
and this was done before pandemic
like i would call it bc and during the
pandemic for the last four months
um you know telemedicine teletherapy
um and especially stress reduction
and depression and anxiety reduction
due using therapeutic uh yoga
especially the one from the premier
institution from india
has been conducting and it still goes on
every day
and we started with 200 attendees from
here and there are boards there
are uh ways the
yoga and yoga therapy yes there are
different
modalities or schools of yoga just like
any other dance in other
alternatives and therapeutic
yoga backed by scientific research
especially with pain mental illness or
mental status done by
national institute of mental health and
neurosciences as well as harvard um
mind body institute has a lot of backing
and uh there is evidence based and
we have to start somewhere and
if this is not the place this was the
second time this was introduced
by me previous time it went to health
and human services with
alternative therapies and it was
i was told that it was i was trying to
boil the ocean with
every alternative therapeutic
intervention
so you know break it down
bring it one at a time or you know i
worked with um
acupuncture as well as uh chiropractors
and uh natural apathy that was the last
bill
and you know we went through that it
said no this is not
the way to do it okay in the insurance
companies
uh said we will you know we need
some kind of uh support from legislation
in order to see if this is doable pilot
so i'm trying whichever way and i know
that this is a modality that is helpful
for
many of my constituents and other than
trying to
bring it free of charge and
you know across the ocean
i'm trying to make this of mainstream
so if this is not the recommendation
i respectfully take that and
i'll continue to work and make this
available because we are in a crisis
and before the pandemic hit we were in
mental health
crisis and we have 80 people waiting in
the
er and the families of
er boarding due to mental illness and
families dealing with that
i'm dealing with phone calls almost on a
weekly basis
begging for some kind of a relief in the
anxiety level
so this is a simple tool that can bring
some kind of a relief at least a coping
strategy it's not a cure all and
end all and be all uh but
if that's not what we are going to look
at
that's fine and i will try my attempt
thank you for asking me to speak and
thank you
for letting me be part of the fly to
hear the discussion
you're muted representative williams
so would anyone else like to speak uh on
uh house bill 1464
i see a hand from representative van
houghton
thank you and um thank you for bringing
your
your expertise to us representative
manjapuri uh
with due respect to what you're saying
i'm just double checking the bill
this is specific to an alternative
substitute for opioids
and i'm not sure that we've been
presented with enough information to see
that that is an alternative therapy
i totally agree with you anxiety uh
headaches all sorts of things
may well may well be not cured but at
least addressed
um by by this kind of therapy and so i
just wanted to mention that at this
point
and again um i know that you have great
insights into this and i do respect that
thank you
this bill was before the pandemic
i was trying to address just the pain
and
anxiety due to pain and overdose because
that was the population that was looking
for
alternative to opioid during when they
get started on opioid
to have another way of dealing with it
and then gradually ease into it
that was the main reason why
i had introduced just for that and
due aft and this post pandemic
during the pandemic what has evolved is
the specifically for anxiety reduction
and stress reduction
during covet 19 and i can send you guys
the studies that has been done with
thousand
people participating over uh
three months with just yoga intervention
and but again
i will bring forth a different bill
and um with
the framework of um
covert 19 in mental health and not
specifically focused on uh pain
and pain management because this was
post
i mean before coleman bc
ac bill would be different after covert
representative butler um i would like to
make a motion
uh go ahead thank you um i would
uh move that uh house bills 1464
not be recommended for future
legislation and if i could just
uh say that even though representative
herbert isn't here
his commentary and when in this
discussion was that uh
yoga has been beneficial for uh
people for 5000 years and we know that
that's the case
but commerce is focused primarily on
how we deal with the insurance issues
and
there is a long way to go uh to get
uh yoga therapy which is obviously
beneficial and many of us agree
to the point of being able to be
reimbursable
service so i would move not recommended
that motion and
and i would i would recommend uh
representative that if you bring
something forward
next year that part of it needs to be to
create some sort of
new hampshire-based uh licensing
or certification because i think to get
new hampshire
insurance companies to pay for services
either voluntarily or
or by statute um there has to be some
way for them to recognize that that
provider is in fact
uh providing a a useful service so i
think
that level of certification even though
i know that there's
national or international certification
um i think there needs to be something
that's new hampshire based
in order to uh to move that forward so
i'd recommend
if you do something that that's part of
what you focus on
and i see no other hand so you can go
ahead with the
vote okay uh vice chairman williams
yes representative gage not here
representative abel uh
yes representative bartlett
yes representative herbert
not here representative macbeth
no representative van houghton
yes representative fargo yes
representative endrick yes
representative weston yes representative
hunt yes representative sanborn not here
representative
osborne yes
representative plummer yes
representative barnes yes
representative to patusek yes
representative warden yes
chair butler
representative butler i somebody had
called
up from the downstairs office so i muted
myself sorry yes
okay fourteen to one
second did that williams thank you
thank you okay so we'll move on to
uh house bill 1697
which is relative to prescription drug
discount prohibition
and is there anyone who would like to
speak on that bill
butler has a hand up
thank you so
there were a variety of bills to
work on reducing the cost of
prescription drugs
this being one of them and
copay coupons and
various coupon programs
i think are still problematic however
house bill 1280 passed a variety
of efforts at um
decreasing the cost of prescription
drugs
and that has gone through the entire
process
and uh the governor has signed it um i
think
we are at a point where we maybe need to
take
uh a breath and see what the
uh pieces of 1280 do
the reduction in insulin costs the
epipen build the prescription
board affordability board
the cross-border
efforts and so
unless others make a better argument i
think at this point
um it was
it was a good idea but uh not something
that should move forward
thank you thank you uh representative
williams and
rep and chair um
mr dave butler george george
um you know this bill this issue um i
appreciate you saying let's take a break
this is an issue that we really do need
to come back to so i'm going to accept
that maybe this first
section of our we um you know first
year of the session that we need to let
it go but the distortion
that these discounts do cause in the
market
is something that has to be addressed
and i really feel like
um it's a it's a good cause before it's
time before we really could educate
the people that are going to get hurt
initially by removing it
so i do appreciate your efforts in this
they are
issues that i know a lot of us will
carry forward and
continue to look at and um thank you for
tying it in
and you know talking about the changes
in 1280 we'll watch that
but this your efforts in this area
they've educated me and a lot of people
so
um you know good work and let's continue
to consider it thank you
and representative abel yes thank you
um since there was
a committee a study committee set up
last year
i want to ask a question of whether we
have any knowledge of whether that
committee is in fact
still studying these issues
because the report is supposed to be
coming this fall
and it seems like we shouldn't be
recommending or not recommending
when that study may come out differently
than what we would
what we would uh vote on i mean is there
a way to say
not give a recommendation if if not then
i guess
we need to do one or the other okay
it certainly doesn't prohibit anything
to come from a study committee
i think you're going to find that study
committees none of them have really been
meeting since march
yeah thank you
anyone else so i i
recognize the absence of representative
muscatel who was a co-sponsor on this
bill and worked on it very hard and
um unfortunately the next time we hear
from him he'll probably be
a legislator in california and not back
in new hampshire but
maybe um but
representative fargo wrote the
blurb in our last iteration and i'm
wondering
if you would make a motion represent
fargo yeah
i'll make a motion to not recommend
moving forward on this and i
i do want to say though i remember a lot
of discussions on this
and how important it is for us to try to
to curb the costs um but my my big
concern at the time and still is the
impact
at um at the pharmacy for people right
now especially during the pandemic and
things like that it's just
it's a very difficult it's going to hurt
a lot of people so
we have we have to find a balance and i
i appreciate what you're saying about
seeing what the rest of this legislation
is going to provide
and um being more measured and i i do
think we need to go
there i just don't think this is the
right time so
with that said second
second representative hunt
and the clerk will call the rule on not
recommended on house bill 1697 when she
is ready
vice chairman williams yes
uh representative gage not here
representative abel
he's not muted and he's is his internet
stuff
he's muted well now he's unbeaten rich
can you hear us
representative abel i think he can
call him on his phone
um want me to give him a call
that would be good and if we could
continue
uh and come back to him representative
bartlett
yes representative herbert not here
representative macbeth
yes representative van houghton yes
representative fargo yes representative
endrick yes representative weston
yes representative hunt yes
representative sanborn not here
representative osborne
yes representative plummer
yes representative barnes yes
representative yes
representative warden yes
and i'm leaving after this vote so thank
you
uh chairman butler yes
and again rich uh representative abel
hello
yes i just called and spoke to you oh
i'm not getting anything roberta sorry
phone isn't working
i'm not getting anything spoke to his
wife i believe a woman in his house
and talk to him and that might have been
her
following him calling him representative
uh abel how do you feel i don't know
what's happened here but i'm not getting
anything
all right we can hear you now can you
hear us your finger
up or down it says
representative abel where we're we're
voting um
that's 15 yays no nays 15 to 0.
thank you
so uh we'll move on to the last item on
today's
uh meeting
and that would be uh hp 1215
relative to the installation of solar
energy systems
in condominiums and homeowners
association
is there anyone who would like to speak
on
this bill so
um i am i have been been the victim of
the uh homeowners uh
and condominium and homeowners uh
uh committee uh for a while now
and i i would say that
this is a very difficult thing to do
um to to make a change
um to to be able to do something like
this
um the same issue that comes up in
almost every issue of condominium law is
who enforces it you know so somebody
wants to be able to put solar panels on
their roof
uh and the association doesn't let them
you know are they going to go to
superior court and spend several
thousand dollars to be able to get
the permission to do that and then the
other issue
which we discussed at length in the in
the uh
hearing about this is what happens if
the roof is shared which is true in a
lot of
uh of condominiums or the the ground is
shared
it's it's common area and not belonging
to one particular
uh apartment or condominium
in those circumstances who's
who's allowed to put the solar panels on
what space
and what happens if the roof leaks
because
somebody misinstalled the solar panels i
think there's just a lot of
issues around
making a rule that allows someone to do
something like this
uh when other people disagree
um it's shared space and so you need to
have
agreement among the the residents in
order to do these kinds of things
and i see representative van houten's
hand
thank you as a condominium owner and
resident
uh there are several issues that really
come up here that the bill really
was the the beginning of something but
not the end of something is a great deal
to be looked at one of the major issues
i think is the
uh percentage i believe simple majority
for this and um i know that in my
association there are lots of issues
that are coming up with the covet issues
um the amenities here were not opened
and
the there was a real hollow blue about
you know why can't we who can vote and
things of that sort
so i think the complexities of this bill
have been brought home to me even more
fully now that we're looking at those
kinds of things
also condominium law is still relatively
new
and i think this might be something that
should be referred back to
i think it's mentioned in the in the
blurb or in the um
um in in the uh written out written
aspect of this
committee to study the laws relating to
condominium condominium and homo
home owners associations excuse me for
stumbling through that
i i think there's a lot more work to be
done on this i absolutely applaud the
idea of solar energy and of
giving access to that but right now i'm
talking to you from the bottom
floor of an eight uh unit condominium
building
and if i wanted to have solar energy i
don't know how i would be able to access
that freestanding condo buildings
probably have a better opportunity to do
that
but nevertheless there are issues of
aesthetics for instance that people are
concerned about
the long and short of it is um i think
the idea of solar energy
certainly is is is valid and worth
looking at but this bill before it's
ready to really go anywhere needs a
great deal of
fine-tuning and a great deal of
contemplation as to how the she
should be brought forward thank you
representative bartlett hi um
thank you i'm going to just reiterate
some of what um
representative manhattan said the thing
that concerns me is the simple majority
vote
um to get to 51 which changes the bylaws
just for this one issue um
i have a problem with i i do no it's not
letting me hear
anything i do recognize that
um two-thirds or
three-quarters majority vote is very
difficult to come to
on many condominium associations
particularly the larger ones
um i don't know
i have a problem with with um
there you know just going to a simple
majority just for this one issue
um even though i think that solar energy
certainly
is important that we use alternative
energies i just don't think
i think this bill has so many problems
i'm i can't
i can't support it as far as
recommending
uh future legislation
two hands in the attendees uh group uh
right gary daddario
and dean lennon have their hands uh
mr didario first sure
hi thank you am i being broadcasted
right now yes
okay excellent um i appreciate the
opportunity to speak on this
uh for those who don't know me my name
is gary d'addario i
oops sorry that was me
trying to bring him in if he had his
video
oh okay sorry about that you you're
you're back now
okay um so uh i'm an attorney who
represents
uh associations uh in new hampshire
and um at the moment i am speaking on
behalf
of the community association institute's
legislative action committee for the
state of new hampshire
my issue with this proposal is that
associations are condominiums are
creatures of statute they exist only
because
governing documents are drafted that
create them and bring them into
existence and those documents are then
recorded
as public records at the registry of
deeds so
everyone who purchases a unit at a
condominium association
does so not only on a voluntary basis
but they do so presumably with knowledge
of these condominium documents
and any restrictions that they contain
and so for that reason i've said this
before but i'll say again
whenever i see a proposal that would in
the law
start out as this does with language
notwithstanding
any greater vote requirement in a
condominium instrument or bylaws
i become frightened that we're probably
not doing a good thing
because these documents exist they are
what
creates the condominium in the first
place unit owners buy their condominium
and choose to live with these
restrictions
and then to the extent that the law
would say well we're going to set those
restrictions aside
i think we're sort of setting the stage
for problems
um other than that i think i would just
reiterate some of the points that have
been made which is that in an
association unit owners typically do not
own
the outside of the building they don't
own the roof they don't own the grounds
and so a number of problems arise to the
extent that unit owners would be allowed
to circumvent
the association's normal voting
standards
and on this lesser basis of a simple
majority vote
start to try to claim the ability to put
things in those spaces
the leaky roof is an issue the notion of
what happens when we run
out of roof space and there are still
unit owners who want to
have solar or what happens if
unit owners disagree about solar that
gets placed on the ground
what happens when someone puts a solar
panel in place and then sells their unit
and moves away
these are all questions that to me
reflect the fact
that association living just really
isn't the right environment
to to undertake actions like this and so
um we're not against solar we recognize
the value of it
um but it seems that to the extent it's
a priority for an individual
um that individual probably needs to be
living in a different sort of
environment than an association
environment
where the outside spaces are are all
shared and not under one's own
ownership
thank you thank you
so pam could you uh promote uh mr lennon
so that he can speak
sure
mr lemon welcome to commerce and you are
muted
can you unmute yourself mr lennon there
you go
okay thank you thank you for the
promotion there uh representative
williams
and thank you for the opportunity to uh
speak i am also on the
cai uh new hampshire legislative action
committee with gary
and i don't want to uh reiterate what
everyone has said but i would certainly
uh support
the comments of representative van
houghton
uh and and my major concern like gary
would be
the 51 vote changing uh what is in
almost every set of docks would be a
minimum of of 67
and at times 75 percent um
and and the issue that you know when
you're talking about installation
typically on the roof
it's almost certainly common area unless
it's
standalone townhouses or single-family
homes within a condo
but you know let's say the installation
goes bad and there's uh a roof leak
who's paying for that
uh what is the basis uh for uh assessing
uh the damages
what if the panels are installed and the
roofs need to be
replaced two years later that owner is
going to be fit to be tied when he asked
to take his
panels off at his own expense and and
put them back on so there's a whole host
of issues
when it comes to community living uh
with solar panels i have solar panels
myself
they're fantastic they pay for
themselves but
those issues i don't live in a
condominium or a community association
uh so there's just a whole host of
issues that are at play there
um and then the issue of aesthetics too
some will have them some will not
um a lot of people move to community
associations because of
uh the uniform aesthetics but thank you
for your time today
and representative mcbet
thank you representative williams so um
i find this issue fascinating and i
think it is extremely important
um i related a little bit to the uh
prohibition that we've heard about
before
of the ham radio antennas on the outside
of condominiums
and i really um i think that we don't
want to i don't want to admit that if
you
want a ham radio or if you want solar
panels on your
residence you can't be part of a
community living
situation so i do think there are issues
within this particular bill that
you know particularly the changing of
the percentage for voting and others
um that you know aren't i'm not
comfortable with but
you know we're not necessarily just
looking at this bill we're looking at
the idea
of um you know freely contracting
you know what you might like in your
collective so i i really i guess i'm
just saying i like the issue i support
moving forward with it it's not a ball
i'm gonna pick up
but um i just um i do see some value in
discussing it
thank you and representative butler
thank you um i just want to
encourage uh those people in
uh cai um and
uh uh folks who are advocates for
uh condominium living that there
have been issues uh in the past that
have come to the legislature
that have needed to have legislative
involvement
this may or may not be one but i
wouldn't just assume
that uh uh because the associations
uh feel that it's uh a threat in some
ways
that it isn't something that uh if
enough
owners uh come to the legislature um
and raise the priority that it isn't
something that
will continue to be discussed and
uh considered and
maybe someday uh uh voted upon
um this bill may not be it and i agree
um that it should not be recommended but
um
uh i i bristle at the
idea that it's not something that the
legislature shouldn't
consider now or in the future
with representative butler that
it shouldn't just that condominiums and
other
homeowners associations shouldn't
operate just on the basis of their
founding documents because those
documents are often written
for the benefit of the developer and
when the developer leaves and the
residents take over they're often not
rewritten
and so those documents aren't
necessarily
uh optimized for clean
and and straightforward operation
uh which is why we have uh the
condominium law in our statutes because
there have been
issues over the years and some of that
some of that kind of medium law is
really about development but a lot of it
is about
operation so i i would agree that this
isn't necessarily
a bill to move forward but that having
uh the state provide some regulation for
condominiums and homeowners associations
is important
and so i see uh mr daddario
uh has his hand up again
okay you can speak if there you go
hi thank you um i just wanted to quickly
apologize
i think it may have been some of my
statements that
um led to the perception that
there's a suggestion made that the
legislature not be involved with
condominiums and i apologize uh
if i was not clear i did not mean to be
stating something quite that bold
certainly the the legislature has been
involved the condominium
act exists other than an association's
individual documents
it's the primary source for us in
explaining
how condominiums need to operate and i'm
sure
that there will be legislative
involvement with condominiums
in the future as well we as a group in
fact have sought
the legislature's assistance in trying
to pass a bill that would allow
associations to foreclose
when they need to on unpaid assessments
that's not the topic for
for today but it's an example of us
understanding that the legislature
absolutely is
involved for the most part i would just
tend to shy away
from as is the case with this bill uh
legislative language that says
notwithstanding the contrary language
and the documents
um so in other words i think that when
the legislature
speaks on issues for condominiums and
put something into law
i think it would be great if it were an
addition
to what exists or an explanation um but
to the extent that it conflicts with
what associations are are otherwise
doing
then it might set the stage for for
problems and here
it's not even so much an issue of the
actual
subject matter solar it's this issue
that
they would change the voting
requirements that otherwise exist in the
community and
as has been said by others to the extent
that those voting
requirements serve just fine for every
other issue
they should probably carry through but
in any event again i just wanted to
apologize for any confusion and note
that
we certainly do see the legislature as
being part of
condominium governance thank you mr
dario and
and i want to thank you for your
participation in the
condominium law committee or your
frequent
frequent attendee and uh we uh we
appreciate your input
and i hope that we get to meet again
uh sometime in the near future
representative bartlett
um i'd like to make a motion mr chair
please um i'd like to
make the motion that we not recommend
this legislation to go forward
thank you is there a second
representative fargo is uh making a
second and not recommended on house bill
and when the clerk is ready she will
call the roll
i'm ready vice chairman williams yes
representative gage not here
representative abel
yes you're here
i lost the sound it came back i don't
know why
magic representative bartlett
yes representative herbert not here
representative macbeth yes
representative van houghton yes
representative fargo
yes representative indrik
yes representative weston yes
representative hunt
representative hunt sorry yes
representative sanborn not here
representative osborne
yes representative plummer
yes representative barnes
yes representative patusik
yes and representative warden
is not here chair butler
one yes three
fourteen to zero thank you um
12 15 is not recommended and
representative bartlett will write
a statement to that effect um
this is a difficult process in some
respects but i think it went really well
um have we missed anything ms marling
that
uh needs to be dealt with before we say
goodbye
no i think you are in great shape and
that worked well
thank you very much can i just say
something um i can't be here tomorrow
so um i would like to say goodbye and
stay well to everybody on the committee
um i'll miss you and hopefully i'll be
back next year
and we'll see you on veto day of course
that's right and you see representative
fargo has her hand up
yeah the if if we made a motion and
we're gonna
do um a committee report do we send that
um
i would assume to ed kermit and pam
that would be great okay
thank you um we'll
uh do this again tomorrow
eight more bills that's right thank you
very much and thanks
thanks for everyone who attended thank
you
bye-bye everybody thank you pam and
staff
yes